Ah! That's good.
Or is it empty?
You can't really tell.
I hope everyone has enjoyed our field trips as much as I have.
It's really been a great time doing this,
and it's been an amazing experience to teach this class.
You're nearing the end of the class
but I hope just the beginning of your journey in computing.
There's a lot more exciting things to do after this,
including taking the courses that we'll be offering starting in April,
but I hope all of you will find more exciting things to do in computing after this class.
It's really been an amazing and wonderful experience for me to teach it,
and it's been a privilege to have so many students from so many different places
in the class and to see how much you've all contributed to make the class great
and the effort that you've put into it.
So I hope everyone has had a great experience.
Stay udacious, and I look forward to seeing you soon.